backbiting of course is prohibited
irrespective whether in Ramadan or
outside Ramadan however would a woman
who complains to her husband about her
mother-in-law
will she be considered as personal as
backlighted regarding backbiting being
Haram any major thing we discussed in
the last episode and there are various
hadith and Quranic verses it's one of
the major sins but as far as a wife
complaining to the husband regarding the
mother-in-law but naturally speaking
something about the mother-in-law with
the mother-in-law would not like anyone
speaking about so it does come in the
category of
like mighty is it a sin is a question
such incidences where a person complains
to someone and
thinks and feels that one's the
complaint is given to the person maybe
there is a correction in action like a
wife complained to the husband about the
mother-in-law or the wife complained to
the husband about a son that he is doing
so instruction which are wrong so the
husband will correct being a father of
the child or maybe one of the two
brothers in growing in community the
father that my brother did so-and-so
thing which is wrong it's speaking ill
about him behind but that is so that the
father can correct the brother so these
things have been permitted because the
main reason while doing this thing
should not be to mock at someone or
should not be to belittle anyone but the
main purpose should be that the person
who the person is complaining about they
should be correction Act and
if you read the commentary of imam an OB
i filed the hadith of say muslim which
we discussed in the last episode hundred
number 62 65 in which the Prophet peace
be upon him he said that do you know
what is backbiting and that's how I said
that the messenger knows the best so the
Prophet said that if someone speaks
about another person behind the back
which you would not like that's called a
backbiting and thus Abbas what if I'm
speaking about the person is true
then it will be called as backbiting if
it's false it would be called a
slandering so based on this the
commentary of this hadith appointing
mama no be he said that backbiting
giveth in six conditions it's permitted
number one he says that if
something is told to a ruler of the land
or to a judge complaining against the
act of another human being who has done
wrong to the person maybe he's stolen
some wealth from you taking your
property away or an injustice to you so
if you go and complain to a ruler or to
a charge against another human being
another Muslim this is permitted because
you warn the wrong to be undone so in
such cases give us this permitted
category number two that if you complain
to someone who you feel that person has
an influence on the person well that an
evil act or a sin and you feel that he
will stop doing that evil act you are
permitted for example if you know of a
friend who's very close to the person
will run evil act or done a sin and if
you tell him that your friend has
insurance also hands the thing or
drinking alcohol and he feel that he has
an influence on the other person and he
can prevent him from doing the thin it's
permitted rookie but so the question
regarding the wife completed husband
either comes in the first category of
the second category either it's and
ingestion to the wife or maybe the wife
wants to tell the husband let you
correct the mother-in-law it may come in
first two categories the remaining four
categories which Imam are no we said key
but can be done the third is that if you
are approaching a Mufti or a religious
person for some religious advice so you
may say that my father and so in fact or
my wife had and so-and-so act and
described that and asked me what should
I do even in this case if you avoid
naming the father or the mother all say
in the third person that my friend's
father they'll do so and so it is
preferable but in such cases while
taking religious advice or a fatwa for a
particular act it's possible the food
category which nobody said that giveth
is permitted if that when you know of a
narrator who is a liar and if he
narrates any hadith so it becomes
incumbent on you to tell the people that
he's a liar or his memories weak because
to protect the Sharia or for example if
someone is selling a slave and if he
knows that there are some bad habits in
the slave or maybe he does adultery so
it's complexity that the person who's
selling it should tell to the buyer that
the slave has so and so false or if a
person asks you that he wants to marry
another person and ask you how will the
person so that becomes obligatory you to
tell the wrong points or the points
which are not correct in that human be
your intention here is not to belittle
that human being your intention here is
not to degrade the person what intention
is to give the right information whether
for marriage or for business in these
cases this is the fourth category where
Imam and no weak says that is permitted
I fight the fifth category is concerned
that if you know a person is doing a
major sin openly I keep drinking openly
or if he's cheating openly wife is
robbing openly so then you can tell the
public at large that this person is a
person who cheats or personal Rob's or
personal discontinuously better or there
is a religious person who you know who
are going further and you know that he's
not a personal truthful so here it's
permitted that you can speak against the
person and the fifth category is that
while and defying a person if someone
asks you for identification at that time
to identify the person you may have to
use his nickname which is the person may
not like like you may have to tell that
the person who shot person who's tall so
here you're using these nicknames to
identify the person with the person may
not like
mainly find if you hear also if you can
avoid this nickname find affection is
the best but if you can avoid you can do
amanhã we have mentioned six categories
in which gibbet is permitted thank you
dr. zakir